it is craft week here at the show and i
am
so excited to get my diy on
with our next guest he's an
environmental lifestyle expert
really kind of first to the party a true
pioneer
and his magazine naturally danny ceo
is jam-packed with amazing tips and
tricks i've actually read this issue
front two back please welcome the
original
danny ceo
that does look like a worn issue i got
to get you a fresh one
well i really i mean it though you were
really
first to the party with all of this and
everybody has sort of
i'm happy to say jumped on a bandwagon
to be
more environmentally conscientious but
you were doing it way before
it was in vogue i think um
it's now gonna be 30 years um
what are we gonna do today we're going
to dye
common cotton things paper things using
this beautiful pink diet and can you
guess
what our one ingredient natural source
will be
danny tell us i mean it's kind of
obvious there's a bowl of avocados right
here but we're using avocado pits
i love that i have a real association
and affinity for avocados
and they're pits and i knew that about
you you did
see how slippery they are i'm gonna grab
it and as they say i'm pretty woman
slippery little suckers they're very
slippery little suckers and that's the
avocado oil that's the flesh so you have
to clean them really well
so like dry them so we're gonna dry them
but you want to get all that
oil off okay so you get them really wet
and what you can do is take a little bit
of just we have a little shot of soap
you can take a little bit of soap
and just get it off because the avocado
oil that's on the outside of the seed
that can actually get onto like whatever
you're dying
oil stains and what we have in the bowl
here we have about you need about six to
eight
uh-huh avocado seeds and you want them
all to be clean okay you put them into
a pot of water okay and then what you do
is that you simmer this for about 45
minutes wait a minute
danny this coloration is not from an
avocado
it is no yes you don't get a green
dot you don't get a brown dot you get
this beautiful pink dye from the sea
you have got to be kidding me i thought
we were actually working with some type
of colored dye and i was like oh i
love rose color this is it this color
is from the inside of the avocado six
avocado seeds and that's all you need
okay easy so what we're gonna do is
simmer this for about 45 minutes
okay and while we're doing that you want
to get your materials you want to dye
ready i mean
this truly looks like one of those
stores you walk in you're like
everything's so beautiful but how much
is it going to cost because it's so chic
it kind of reminds me of that story abc
we like the same thing
so i see the pits and the color and
everything but i want to know exactly
how to do this
you know i'm not a pro pro at this but
what i do know is you want to fold
whatever you're tie dyeing sort of like
as many ways that you want twist it
around
but i just fold it a couple of times to
take rubber bands and then you kind of
tightly
just wrap the rubber bands around and
around so then after 45 minutes you want
to let the dye cool down
so you know you don't burn your fingers
so it's not like boiling over
and you put it in the die like this
and then what i like to do drew is that
i actually let it
soak overnight but i also find that i
let it sit out for a day or two and then
i wash it in cold water
that's perfect oh good yeah that's
perfect i'm doing it right
so we have a bowl of cold water here
you're gonna take the one that's been
cooking
in the in the one that's already in
there and we're just gonna you know
rinse it out
and then we get to do the fun part you
have to do the reveal
what you could do if you want to be
really really eco is to actually take
them off
and reuse the rubber bands uh-oh okay
good news i
failed the first one i will succeed on
the seconds
ready one two three
oh wow
danny this is gorgeous
and i have to tell you you can't really
get this
color in the dye world like this is so
unique you know what there's also a
study that says that pupils dilate when
you see
uh something that you associate with
pleasure
so guess what
my pupils are like
danny this is so beautiful
you can dry it and stuff it with a fresh
pillow
and i should point out the tutorial for
this avocado dyeing project is in the
winter issue which comes out december
[Applause]
[Music]
3rd